Oh oh well and I'm testing out this new
thing which is to make a tutorial week
for you guys
this will be my first one and this is
only for my patreon followers and just
as a little inside tip I'm inside my
practice space and this one was
requested by Danielle good so check it
out good today we're going to learn how
to do a fujimi I can kind of do one side
pretty cleanly and looks like this this
is with a really little staff more
similar to what you'd see a baton
twirler do this with this is an old good
more staff that I did a routine with
Danielle and Justin with a long time ago
but that's the basics of fujimi I
started learning through jaimeson little
staffs I like that because it kind of
increased the speed of your vertical
rotation and so yeah so you might want
to do that too
alright so the basics of fujimi I
learned this from Michelle Smith from
Vancouver Canada she's an amazing batons
winner
maybe converting more and more to staff
and other types of things but she taught
me this at Matt was Vancouver circus
festival a few years back so one of the
things that really got me in the
workshop is that a stand in your wheel
planes a lot of times you see people
trying to do it like this the plane and
the twisting really makes a difference
so we're going to do a forward fujimi
first I know that's and probably that'll
be the only thing in the video I hold
the staff my right hand now it's on my
left side the way you're going to learn
a lot of contact staff tricks is you
walk your way through it so it does a
little hand wrap right and it goes on to
elbow
and then you can hold this staff and
rotate to the other side then it comes
out so in faster motion stop holding
motion kind of achieved TV and it's not
exactly a fujimi but this will be the
basics of just how one side of it could
work and so when you want to start
getting into the actual fujimi you do
that same thing and when it gets to the
this part you're going to push up this
part has to go up and tip down onto the
same elbow on the other side so I showed
that again really close the tips up and
then goes down okay so here I am setting
a wheel plane bringing my staff the
other side I do a hand wrap and tips up
close jeez that was a bad one comes down
okay so one more time and it's really
hard to succeed so yeah so from the
other side for those left-handed people
these are not looking really I'd like
them to be today that's okay
sometimes when you yam your contact
staff game it's just not a good day so
you know that so here I am doing it in
fast motion again and some tips that
Aneta Lucero told me is that this plane
or the plane of the staff has to be
highly vertical so a lot of the motion
right here is more like a push okay a
little push okay I want to show that
really close so you can do that
it's hard to do with my knees here okay
so I'll show you from the front okay and
you can do both sides
I always called this one the cheat G me
the full GG me where you do a Fuji maybe
hand hand
we gave me beat hand hand to keep me
beat
hand hand Jimmy B hand hand and this
will get you into the continuous through
G me and I can do about six after
warming over twenty minutes but I'll try
to get two for you right now but that's
the continuous fujimi you could tell
that the action of the staff that was a
cheating one the action of the staff is
really slow and I actually think that's
a detriment to the bougie me so okay
we're 10 that's my first tutorial about
the food gave me for my patreon
followers and that I just want to say
thanks a lot for supporting me in my
spinning journey
you